bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité et proposer du temps à nos
experts pour comprendre les mutations de
notre société et les crises que nous
traversons voici le sommaire de ce
premier février quel armes doit-on
livrer à l'Ukraine la question est au
cœur des offensives militaires et
diplomatiques de ces derniers jours la
France annonce la livraison de 12 canons
Césars supplémentaires les États-Unis
refuse de fournir des avions de combat
comment soutenir un état assiéger
défendre nos valeurs sans devenir
cobelligérants et sur cette ligne de
crête que nous avancerons dans une
minute et puis pour notre débat de
société cette question comment réduire
la fracture numérique en France 13
millions de Français souffrent de ce que
l'on appelle l'électronisme ce sont
souvent des associations qui les aident
nous dans les associations on a un peu
l'impression qu'on
récupère toutes les personnes qui
et qui peuvent pas être autonomes quoi
donc quelque part on devient un peu du
parapublic
moderniser nos services publics sans les
déshumaniser voilà le défi que nous
allons analyser dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord un Ukrainien à
Paris le président du Parlement rusla ne
Stephen chouk était reçu aujourd'hui au
Sénat visite symbolique entre
remerciements et opérations séduction
pour intégrer l'Union européenne Marion
Delpech
[Applaudissements]
des sénateurs
après le discours du président de la
Rada le Parlement ukrainien à quelques
heures seulement du sommet prévu à Kiev
avec les 27
tribune du sauna français je voudrais
appeler l'Europe et la communauté
rapidement et sans hésitation
comme une famille
accepte reçoit un guerrier qui revient à
la maison après une guerre terrible un
guerrier qui a gagné qui a protégé sa
famille sa terre notre avenir européen
le président du Sénat Gérard Larcher a
tenu à rappeler le caractère
exceptionnel de ce moment et de la venue
de rousland Stéphane choukalattribune de
la chambre haute jamais les missiles du
Sénat a accueilli le président du
Parlement d'un pays en guerre
cela a fait même plus de 20 ans c'était
en 2003 qu'aucun président d'une
assemblée d'un pays étranger que s'est
exprimé à l'attribut hier c'est devant
les députés français qu'il appelait à
reconnaître la Russie en tant qu'État
hétéro risque pour lutter contre
l'agresseur le président du parlement
ukrainien appelé des pour une aide
militaire accrue
les Léopards les Abrahams les
challengers
l'éclairs français qui nous renforcerons
au sol mais également les mirages et les
rafales qui ensemble avec d'autres
avions de nos alliés protégeront le ciel
ukrainien
donnez-nous les avions
donne-nous les ailes de notre victoire
un sujet que le président du parlement
ukrainien a pu évoquer directement avec
Emmanuel Macron au cours d'une réunion
officielle avant de remercier le Chef de
l'État sur son compte Twitter alors que
la France prévoit la livraison de 12
qu'annoncent Césars supplémentaires les
livraisons d'armes lourdes divisent la
classe politique craignant de dépasser
une ligne rouge plusieurs parties
d'opposition réclament débat sur le rôle
que doit tenir la France dans le conflit
la première ministre a-t-elle tenue à
réaffirmer le soutien de la France dans
toutes ses dimensions pour être aux
côtés de l'Ukraine jusqu'à la victoire
et je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Marie Dumoulin bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice du
programme Europe élargi du cercle de
réflexion
ecfr Conseil européen pour les relations
extérieures Cédric Perrin bonsoir
sénateur LR du Territoire de Belfort et
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées Michel Duclos bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi ancien
ambassadeur et conseiller spécial à
l'Institut Montaigne et Mathieu
croissanto éditoris politique bonsoir
Mathieu bienvenue à vous je commence
avec vous Marie Dumoulin notre soutien
aux Ukrainiens est-il en train de
changer un peu de dimension de changer
d'échelle d'une certaine façon alors je
crois que ça n'est pas seulement un
autre soutien aux Ukrainiens qui est en
train de changer c'est plus généralement
un changement dans le dans l'approche
qu'on les Occidentaux de leur aide à
l'Ukraine avec je crois deux dimensions
qui sont toutes les deux d'ailleurs liés
à la gestion du temps dans ce conflit
une première dimension qui est
la prise de conscience que ce conflit va
s'inscrire dans la durée et que plus il
dure plus l'Ukraine sera détruite et
plus la durée de ce conflit finalement
joue en faveur de la Russie et donc
l'idée du côté des Occidentaux qu'on a
plutôt intérêt à donner les moyens à
l'Ukraine de reprendre l'initiative pour
mettre fin à ce conflit de manière plus
rapide d'où un changement qualitatif des
types d'armes qui sont qui sont fournis
le deuxième changement il est aussi lié
à la nature à la durée du conflit
certains équipements ont été fournis par
les occidentaux depuis le début de la
guerre je pense en particulier au char
d'assaut on a fourni des chars qui
étaient de production soviétiques parmi
les alliés qui ont disposaient encore
ces chars on ne peut pas les produire on
ne peut pas fournir de pièces détachées
on ne peut pas fournir de munitions et
donc si le conflit dur il faut par
définition commencer à amorcer une
transition vers des équipements dont on
maîtrise le cycle de production des
choses que nous produisons nous-mêmes
d'où la décision sur les chars léopards
qui s'inscrit vraiment dans cette
logique là Cédric perron viendra
notamment sur cette question de
maîtriser le cycle de production des
armes que l'on que l'on fournit Cédric
Perrin sur cette visite recevoir le
président du du parlement
ukrainien alors évidemment beaucoup de
symboles il disposant voilà en une
certaine façon sur le terrain des
valeurs de la démocratie il dit voilà
accueillez nous comme on accueille un
soldat qui revient du front c'est ce que
vous avez retenu vous de de son discours
de son de cette venue moi ce que j'ai
retenu c'est évidemment une grande
émotion dans la dans l'assemblée cet
après-midi
avec un moment très particulier qu'on ne
évidemment vit pas tous les jours le
président a rappelé tout à l'heure en
disant que
jamais un président de Parlement en
guerre ne s'était exprimé devant le
Sénat donc on a eu conscience de vivre
un moment historique et très particulier
et c'était très émouvant dans la mesure
où le président de la Rada était déjà
venu au Sénat il y a quelques mois et où
cet appel au secours à évidemment fait
beaucoup d'écho
après on est évidemment dans une dans
une émotion dans un moment particulier
il faut aussi je pense sur cette
problématique prendre beaucoup de recul
et essayer de comprendre
de quelle manière nous pouvons
évidemment aider les Ukrainiens sans
aller trop loin je pense qu'il y a aussi
aujourd'hui une escalade qui est qu'il
faut mesurer qu'il faut prendre en
considération et essayer de d'apporter
en tout cas une aide qui permet à
l'Ukraine évidemment de se battre avec
efficacité en restant dans la mesure et
en évitant l'escalade qui serait
incontrôlable même si on a déjà atteint
aujourd'hui un point je pense de nos
retours alors ce mot escalade il est
évidemment sur toutes les lèvres depuis
plusieurs jours et on y reviendra Michel
Duclos est-ce que c'est une nouvelle
forme de guerre à laquelle on assiste
depuis malheureusement bientôt un an
c'est à dire c'est une guerre locale
mais au conséquences mondiales est-ce
que vous diriez ça
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur la Syrie et
donc la Syrie c'était une guerre
civile globalisée là c'est pas une
guerre civile c'est une guerre entre
deux pays il y en a un qui est agressé
l'autre mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un
prolongement
global dire que c'est une guerre guerre
totale guerre mondiale ça c'est excessif
bien entendu mais c'est une guerre qui a
des ramifications effectivement bien
au-delà de de la Russie Ukraine et
est-ce qu'on vit un moment charnière là
on l'a dit plusieurs fois depuis le
début malheureusement comme il dure
grosso modo au début de la guerre
beaucoup a le cul en Occident croyaient
que l'Ukraine allait plier quand on
s'est aperçu que c'était pas le cas
c'est dit il faut quand même les aider
et puis ils ont repris le dessus à un
moment donné
et après
cet été après le chute de Carson pour
voir le sentiment qu'il y avait une
dynamique en faveur de l'Ukraine mais
maintenant on est dans une autre
situation qui est celle où les Russes
ont cautions se repliés sur un salon de
position mais maintenant ils ont des
bastions qui peuvent tenir plus
facilement et du surcroît premièrement
ils peuvent les renforcer par un renfort
de troupes fraîches si la mobilisation
fonctionne certains disent que ce sera
pas le cas mais enfin c'est quand même
possible que ça ça fonctionne et puis
surtout Marie Dumoulin l'a indiqué les
Russes sont en position détruire le
les villes
ukrainiennes le quartier après quartier
ou installation énergétique après la
sélection énergétique et pour moi c'est
ça qui doit le plus si vous voulez nous
nous interpeller il y a une sorte
d'asymétrie tant que les Russes peuvent
s'en prendre aux arrières du pays alors
que nous ne sommes interdits d'aider les
Ukrainiens à atteindre le territoire
russe là une asymétrie fondamentale et
donc dans cette dans ce moment charnière
comme vous dites où on attend de savoir
si les Russes vont passer l'offensive ou
si au contraire les Ukrainiens vont
pouvoir reprendre la contre-offensive
il y a effectivement un péril qui est
celui d'un englisement du conflit là
aussi je rejoins ce que disait Marie
serait au détriment des Ukrainiens et à
notre détriment l'autre péril c'est la
destruction progressive de toute
l'Ukraine et il me semble que donc d'un
point de vue n'a pas émotionnel mais
d'un point de vue Analytics stratégique
notre intérêt c'est d'essayer les
Ukrainiens à sortir de ce piège de ce
double piège et donc ça pose
effectivement la question des armes de
quelles armes on livre et Mathieu ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est aussi un
débat politique les parties d'opposition
réclament un débat sur sur cette
question des livraisons d'armes oui un
an après le début du conflit et alors
que la France accélère la livraison de
matériel militaire l'Ukraine et
s'interroge par la voix du chef de
l'État sur la possibilité d'amplifier
son effort les oppositions réclament un
débat et c'est à gauche notamment Parti
communiste que la demande s'est fait
entendre les conséquences d'un tel
engrenage doivent pouvoir être mesurés
par la représentation nationale
sommes-nous prêts à assumer le risque
d'entrer en guerre avec la Russie ça
c'est ce qu'on écrit à la fois le patron
des députés communistes André Chassaigne
et le secrétaire national du Parti
Fabien Roussel alors on rappelle
qu'officiellement on peut pas parler de
guerre avec la Russie en tout cas pas
dans la bouche du chef de l'État qui a
toujours pris soin de bien préciser que
nous n'étions pas en guerre avec la
Russie quitte à refroidir parfois les
relations
avec Kiev il l'a fait en mai dernier il
l'a répété sur France 2 en octobre
dernier nous ne sommes pas en guerre
nous aidons les hommes et les femmes du
crâne à résister précisant même nous
n'avons jamais attaqué la Russie mais il
est vrai et on va en parler là que la
livraison de matériel militaire
terrestre plus lourd ou d'avion de
chasse puisque ça a été évoqué nous fait
sans doute franchir un palier et qui
dépays légitime de penser que le
Parlement pourrait au moins être
consulté ou en tout cas que ce sujet
puisse être débattu sur cette question
alors évidemment on parle des
oppositions de qu'est-ce qu'on connaît
les points de vue les positions des uns
et les autres c'est vrai que ça devient
intéressant à gauche la nupes est
divisée les socialistes par la voie
d'Olivier Faure soutiennent les
livraisons d'armes même lourdes pour que
ce conflit s'achève les écologistes ne
sont pas contre non plus même s'ils le
disent pas aussi ouvertement mais les
communistes mettent en garde eux au nom
alors contre le risque évidemment d'une
troisième guerre mondiale c'est-à-dire
d'une d'une escalade mondiale du conflit
les insoumis eux réclament un débat mais
ils noient le poisson quand on leur
demande une position précise vos
souvenir qu'en mars dernier vous
souvenez Jean-Luc Mélenchon s'était fait
Hué dans l'hémicycle assemblée lorsqu'il
avait regretté la livraison d'armes à
l'Ukraine par l'Union européenne et puis
plus près de nous le 30 novembre dernier
le groupe LFI à l'Assemblée toujours a
refusé de voter une résolution de
soutien à l'Ukraine qui invitait le
gouvernement en lien avec ses
partenaires européens a poursuivre et à
renforcer les livraisons d'armes à
destination de l'Ukraine ça c'est une
position qu'on retrouve aussi de l'autre
côté
au rassemblement national qui avait
refusé lui aussi de voter cette
résolution de soutien et qui sait élever
lui aussi contre la livraison de char
lourds à l'Ukraine enfin la possibilité
de de l'éventualité de livraison de
Charlot à l'Ukraine par la bonne Marine
Le Pen qui elle aussi argumente sur le
thème de l'internationalisation du
conflit et qu'elle redoute et chez LR
enfin vous me corrigerez peut-être mais
il y a on n'est pas non plus pour
l'envoi de matériel lourd mais avec un
autre argument j'ai trouvé chez Olivier
warlex qui est on n'a pas les moyens de
s'affaiblir c'est un petit peu un petit
peu autre chose on y reviendra
évidemment que répond la
pour l'instant explique-t-on en
substance dans la majorité on redoute
que ce débat ne soit qu'une manœuvre
pour retarder d'éventuelles livraisons
ou noyer le poisson même si certains
députés de la majorité il verrait quand
même une bonne occasion de rappeler ORL
comme aux insoumis leur tranchant pro
russe et leurs errements propulsinent
alors ça pose plusieurs questions
passionnantes et on reprendra la
citation de famille Roussel sommes-nous
prêts à assumer le risque d'entrer en
guerre avec la Russie j'aime bien j'ai
hâte de vous entendre là-dessus mais
d'abord effectivement là la question de
voilà est-ce qu'on a les moyens de de
livrer autant et plus d'armes c'est
c'est un peu la ligne de LR c'est ça
la ligne de l'air je sais pas moi je
vais vous donner la ligne que je
défendre moi ce que je voudrais dire au
préalable c'est déjà enfin je voudrais
pas pour vous corriger mais je pense que
les mots ont un sens et que comme dans
la dissuasion nucléaire il y a une
grammaire et bien je pense que dans les
conflits il y a une grammaire nous ne
sommes pas en guerre les choses soient
claires je pense qu'il faut dire les
choses très clairement il y a un
président de la République il y a
quelques années qui expliquait au moment
où des attentats que nous étions en
guerre et que contre
un certain nombre de pays et que les
Parisiens pouvaient continuer à être aux
terrasses des cafés à bord leur café
tranquillement non nous ne sommes pas en
guerre si nous étions en guerre je pense
que les choses seraient différentes on
parle aujourd'hui d'économie de guerre
de la même manière je suis assez
critique sur cette question alors où on
place le curseur mais la question c'est
de savoir où placer le curseur moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vous disiez les LR
sont pas pour l'envoi de matériel lourd
etc c'est pas ça la question en fait la
vraie question c'est de se poser de
s'interroger sur l'utilité du matériel
qu'on va envoyer sur de l'efficacité qui
va pouvoir avoir si on l'envoie en
Ukraine prenons l'exemple des chars
Leclerc dont le président de la Rada
tout à l'heure a dit qu'il espérait
pouvoir avoir des livraisons moi je
voudrais expliquer que aujourd'hui pour
être efficace il faut à minima avoir une
brigade blindée une brigade blindée
c'est une centaine d'unités de chat
peut-être un peu plus tout dépend des de
l'organisation qu'on met en place et
c'est à ce niveau là que ce joue
j'allais lire le soutien matériel en
termes de munitions en termes de
logistique en termes de Chen un
changement de chenille de dépannage et
autres et la multiplication des types de
matériels ne ferait finalement que
pénaliser les Ukrainiens dans le dans le
dans le dans le processus de
d'utilisation de ces matériaux donc si
plusieurs pays d'Europe livres de
léopards ça sert à rien de livrer
Leclerc les capteurs challenger 2
non finalement de l'intérêt parce que
ils sont évidemment un outil de
communication mais je pense que
l'important aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
avoir des brigades blindées qui soient
équipées de léopard et qui permettent
d'avoir aux Ukrainiens en tout cas des
moyens offensifs
je pense qu'il faut que la France
peut-être ait une réflexion différente
et qu'on essaye peut-être d'avoir une
approche
un peu plus un peu plus pragmatique en
se disant qu'on peut peut-être leur
livrer comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
avec des Césars qui viennent d'être
comment j'allais dire annoncé par le par
le ministre de de des armées et bien des
matériels de défense et d'anticipation
qui pourraient permettre d'accompagner
ces armes lourdes qui sont livrées par
les autres pays je parle de de de de
matériel Ant facile antidrone de radar
de haute de haute de qualité importante
telle qu'on en a chez nous etc
une réponse technique mais militaire
parlons d'une réponse politique si vous
étiez au pouvoir et que le président de
ski vous demandez des chars et des
avions de chasse qu'est-ce que vous pour
répondre moi je pense que sur la logique
elle a toujours été de dire qui avait
trois j'allais dire il y a trois points
sur lesquels on ne veut pas aller c'est
à dire d'abord l'escalade c'est ensuite
la capacité qu'on pourrait donner à la à
l'Ukraine d'aller frapper en Russie sans
le souhaite pas et ça a toujours été
très clairement annoncé et puis ça a été
dit vous l'avez déjà Olivier Marley la
capacité qu'on aurait à ne pas se
désarmer parce que je rappelle tout à
l'heure ça a été dit par Madame que ni
les Léopards aujourd'hui ni les Leclerc
ne sont plus produits
et une un des sujets derrière tout ça
c'est comment les pays occidentaux qui
livrent des armes de manière intensive à
l'Ukraine sont en capacité de renouveler
leur stock de munitions leur stock de
matériel non et aujourd'hui ça n'existe
pas chez nous alors donc on se livre aux
Américains et aux Comoriens du Sud ce
mot-là escalade se risque d'escalade je
voudrais vous entendre l'une et l'autre
là-dessus peut-être Marie du moulin pour
pour commencer alors le risque
d'escalade en réalité il existe depuis
le début de la guerre on a un conflit de
haute intensité qui se joue au port de
l'Europe donc il suffit de pas grand
chose pour que ça déborde et que
effectivement des pays de l'OTAN donc
l'OTAN se retrouve engagé dans ce
conflit je pense pas que ça dépend de
décision qui serait prise délibérément
d'un côté ou de l'autre d'ailleurs parce
que je j'ose croire que les Russes
au-delà de leur rhétorique qui consiste
à dire qui ne sont pas en guerre contre
l'Ukraine mais contre une coalition de
pays et globalement contre l'OTAN je
pense que au-delà de cette rhétorique
ils sont bien conscients que ils sont en
difficulté face à une armée ukrainienne
soutenue par les occidentaux il serait
dans des difficultés encore plus
importantes s'ils effectivement en face
de l'OTAN donc je pense qu'il
ne chercheront pas à aller vers cet
affrontement au-delà de la rhétorique et
éventuellement d'action de subversion
etc du côté occidental on l'a bien vu
lorsque un débris de missile était tombé
en territoire polonais il y a eu une
extrême prudence dans la réaction
précisément pour ne pas se retrouver
engagé dans une escalade de ce type
prudence diplomatique occidentale moins
de prudence de la part de volodières
zellenski
[Musique]
son pays est en guerre comprendre des
erreurs
ce qui s'était passé donc la
communication elle a été faite un peu
sérieux
l'Ukraine par ailleurs à certainement un
intérêt aussi à amener à plus de soutien
des Occidentaux et donc
voilà et donc à une forme d'escalade
aussi
encore une fois pour moi cet escalade
elle ne résultera pas de décisions qui
seraient prise et donc je pense pas non
plus que ça dépend vraiment de la nature
des équipements qui seraient fournis
sauf effectivement si on se retrouvait
dans une situation où des avions de
fabrication américaine bombarder le
territoire ruche là effectivement ça
pourrait être mal pris Mathieu pour
poser la question autrement quand est-ce
qu'on devient cobelligérant c'est quand
on a des hommes sur le terrain ou quand
on a du matériel sur terrain parce qu'on
quand on frappe quand on d'abord la
notion de cobayes en pratique elle n'est
plus vraiment utilisée on parle plutôt
de parties au conflit et une partie au
conflit c'est quelqu'un qui prend part
au combat donc il faut pour ça avoir des
troupes qui sont engagés dans les
combats tant que on s'en tient à des
livraisons d'armement comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs avec un certain nombre de
pays qui ont été en conflit dans
l'histoire on n'est pas parti à ce
conflit
sur le plan juridique sur le plan
politique c'est évidemment une question
différente et encore une fois de ce
point de vue là la Russie depuis le
début de cette guerre dit être en guerre
contre l'OTAN
sans pour autant voilà
la formulation de de députés communistes
et de Fabien Roussel sommes-nous prêt
assumer le risque d'entrer en guerre
avec la Russie est-ce que c'est un
risque réel ça
je crois qu'il y a risquerait que la
Russie entre guerre avec nous c'est vrai
et si vous voulez sur cette notion
d'escalade je vous avouerai que je suis
un peu partagé parce que une part de
moi-même le stratège trouve que c'est
absurde parce que si vous indiquez votre
adversaire que vous êtes pas prêt à
monter vous lui donnez déjà un avantage
maintenant l'autre part de moi-même qui
est le le politique ou le tous les cas
le citoyen le responsable je comprends
très bien que pour nos hommes politiques
c'est important de donner l'impression
qu'on n'est pas des vatang guerre
justement et donc à la fois vis-à-vis de
notre public et aussi de de la Russie de
de montrer que nous nous restons dans la
sobriété que c'est pas nous qui voulons
monter aux extrêmes maintenant j'ai pas
utilisé
vous savez clause vite c'est le grand
théoricien de ces choses là a dit que
tout conflit implique une montée aux
extrêmes et donc compte tenu de ce qui
est jusqu'ici la détermination de
Vladimir Poutine qui ne pense pas avoir
perdu qui pense qu'il a encore des
cartes à jouer dans la durée on peut pas
complètement exclure qu'à un moment
donné y est un choc entre la Russie et
des et des forces de l'Alliance
atlantique ça c'est je pense que ce
serait imprudent de l'exclure et je
pense que j'espère que nos responsables
politiques
préparent ce type de scénario de crise
on a évoqué tout à l'heure l'affaire de
alors je précise pour que pour l'instant
effectivement les Russes ont l'air de de
respecter parfaitement l'article 5 et
effectivement l'affaire du
des débris de
missiles qui sont tombés du côté
polonais c'était assez typique parce que
la réaction était très prudente et
mesurée du côté occidental mais aussi du
côté russe et les Russes n'ont pas
cherché à exploiter cette affaire donc
pour l'instant cette espèce de règle de
retenue mutuelle
entre la Russie et les Occidentaux
semblent fonctionner au moins sur
l'aspect uraniable parce que sur
l'aspect Gary brides attaque de
propagande etc c'est autre chose alors
entrer un peu dans le détail des armes
que que l'on prévoit de livrer une
propose écouter une première réaction
celle de la première ministre Elisabeth
borde qui évoque notamment ses 12 canons
César supplémentaires
ce sont des équipements qui font la
différence sur le terrain je pense aux
canons César au lance-roquettes unitaire
ou encore au système entier aérien
crotale nous sommes prêts à étudier les
demandes supplémentaires des Ukrainiens
en veillant au respect de trois
principes
d'abord notre aide ne doit pas provoquer
d'escalade ensuite elle doit être
utile et efficace rapidement enfin elle
ne doit pas affaiblir nos propres
capacités de défense
[Musique]
me permettre allez-y
sur les matériels qui ont été cités par
la première ministre à l'instant certes
les
Césars qui sont au matériel
particulièrement efficaces et ils n'ont
prouvé depuis quelques mois maintenant
en Ukraine peuvent être fabriqués
puisque je rappelle qu'on a commandé 12
un externe pas plus tard que au
lendemain quasiment de l'envoi des 12 en
[Musique]
Ukraine et donc n'exter peut monter en
puissance et toute l'intérêt de
l'économie de guerre qui a été mise en
avant et annoncé par le président de la
République l'objectif c'est l'entreprise
française flux tendu aujourd'hui
d'augmenter ces chaînes de production à
la condition d'avoir des commandes ça
j'insiste là-dessus quand même une
guerre ça suppose aussi d'avoir des
commandes par contre si on commence à
parler de elle et les rues qui sont les
formules lance-roquettes unitaires qui
sont disposés au premier régiment
d'artillerie dans le Territoire de
Belfort à Bourogne sont des matériels
qui n'existent plus dont on est doté à
hauteur de 12 matériels dont 8 seulement
qui aujourd'hui on le sait sont en état
de fonctionnement et trois qu'on a déjà
livré à l'Ukraine donc ça limite quand
même assez considérablement notre
capacité
d'aller donner du matériel et puis comme
je dis la plus belle femme du monde ne
peut donner que ce qu'elle a et à un
moment donné on est quand même très très
limité par la capacité qu'on a
aujourd'hui de par une construction de
de notre comment outil de défense qui
qui a été basé essentiellement et qui
continue de l'aide sur la dissuasion et
sur le fait qu'on est doté et d'ailleurs
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire le montrera il y aura
évidemment un affrontement entre ceux
qui considèrent que la dissuasion
nucléaire est en quelque sorte la
nouvelle ligne Maginot du président de
la République et ceux qui considèrent
qu'il faut de l'artillerie et qu'ils
font une une arme conventionnelle une
dissuasion conventionnelle non c'est le
fond des choses c'était effectivement la
dissuasion plus les interventions
extérieures donc nous tout simplement on
n'avait pas de matos et quand dans une
dans cette guerre multiforme il y a eu
plusieurs dimensions une des diminution
de dimensions c'est la compétition entre
les soutiens à l'Ukraine à celui qui est
le le plus fort dans l'Ukraine
le meilleur des alliés quoi
ont été les champions parce que
justement eux avaient des 2014
effectivement nous on a fait avec ce
qu'on a pu et donc c'est assez logique
que on cherche à être le plus utile
possible et donc à faire la différence
par le type d'armement que que l'on
transfert et jusqu'ici avec un certain
succès parce que les humeurs par exemple
c'était les les Césars ça a été un vrai
succès j'ai posé une question qui va
peut-être
une question de bossien mais
qui paye n’extérieur qui paye est-ce que
c'est l'Ukraine qui paye est-ce que on
détend on retarde je sais pas lequel de
vous veut répondre à cette question
Marie Dumoulin peut-être je suis pas sûr
d'avoir la réponse il y a un fond de
soutien qui a été mis en place sur une
base bilatérale par la France de 200
millions d'euros de mémoire sur
laquelle l'Ukraine peut commander un
certain nombre d'équipements il y a
aussi un outil européen qui s'appelle la
facilité européenne de paix qui permet
de financer certains des achats de
l'Ukraine il y a évidemment derrière
tout ça le financement j'allais dire par
le contribuer plus que de toute façon
une un des la loi de finances à montrer
que le budget de l'an dernier a été
amputé les opérations extérieures
c'est-à-dire les opérations qu'on fait
sur barkhane et autres plus les
opérations intérieures c'est centimes ça
coûte à traditionnellement un milliard
deux un milliard trois cette année on a
eu un dépassement de l'heure de 600
millions d'euros qui sont liés à la
fourniture d'armes à l'Ukraine donc on
les paye sur le budget de la défense
c'est-à-dire le fameux pour ceux les 146
donc je suis le rapporteur d'ailleurs et
la nécessité de reconstituer les stocks
et elle est là et une des questions
importantes que posent les
parlementaires quelques bords qu'ils
soient c'est évidemment de savoir
comment on reconstitué les stocks avec
quels moyens et de quel de quelle
manière ce sera pris en compte dans la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
c'est un évidemment un souci majeur
parce qu'au-delà de la capacité à
produire plus vite il faut aussi pouvoir
faire des commandes vous avez les chars
Leclerc on en construisait plus depuis
2008 2008 est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on
va relancer la construction d'un nouveau
chat pour acheter des charlés au pain le
problème derrière tout ça c'est qu'il y
a le fameux projet de char du futur du
futur le fameux mgcs qu'on doit faire
avec les allemands dont ola Schulz a
très bien compris que lorsqu'il a
demandé aux Allemands aux Américains de
lui garantir la livraison de
charabrahams pour compléter les chars
léopards qu'il allait livrer il donnait
il ouvrait la porte aux Américains en
Europe pour livrer les chars lourds et
tout ça ça a des conséquences puisque
potentiellement ça peut largement
pénaliser la mise en oeuvre du char du
futur que Nexter avec ryanmetal les
Allemands et les Français sont en train
de de mettre en oeuvre et voilà donc il
y a broumoute beaucoup de problématiques
le char Leclerc n'est plus fabriqué
depuis 2008 rappelez-vous du scandale de
jatte industrie enfin je veux pas
revenir là-dessus mais il la cible est
terminé 500 on en a fabriqué 400 et
aujourd'hui on en a 200 avec quelques et
160 qui sont en état de fonctionner donc
on est quand même limité alors on a
entendu les les trois conditions
évoquées par par première ministre qui a
repris c'est évidemment le discours de
d'Emmanuel Macron alors le président de
la Rada du parlement
ukrainien qui était donc au Sénat
aujourd'hui à répondu à Elisabeth borne
c'est mathiasaray Fabien Ricard et
Adrien qui l'ont rencontré on écoute ou
slam Stéphane shock nous connaissons et
nous acceptons les conditions de la
France pour nous livrer de l'armement je
tiens à rappeler ici que nos militaires
ont fait la preuve de leur capacité à se
former et à maîtriser rapidement les
armements sophistiqués de l'OTAN et leur
utilisation dans la stratégie militaire
ce qui compte pour nous c'est la
décision politique de nous livrer cette
armement
il y a eu un peu de cacophonie côté
occidental ces derniers jours alors là
on a beaucoup parlé des charges et qu'on
parle des des avions de combat il y a eu
entre Joe byzen à côté Emmanuel Macron
de l'autre ce sentiment d'avoir des des
un peu de dissonances je veux dire ça
comme ça comment vous réagissez
ce serait préférable honnêtement que les
chefs d'été de gouvernement des pays
occidentaux ce coordonne dans leur
annonces parce que là on est quand même
dans une affaire manifestement très
grave très sérieux et donc il faut se
concerter au maximum et avoir
une attitude la plus la plus concertée
possible je ne sais pas quelle est la
portée exacte des propos de du président
Biden parce qu'il a été pris un peu à
l'improviste par une question non
préparait dans un contexte un peu un peu
particulier mais d'une certaine façon
c'est quand encore plus révélateur parce
que c'est dans ces cas-là qu'on dit ce
qu'on a vraiment ça pas été relu trois
fois par 15 conseillers et il est
probable qu'effectivement il n'a pas
envie de transférer des avions parce que
c'est escale à toi pour reprendre la
formulation du président français parce
que ça dépend si pour assurer le
contrôle de l'espace aérien
alors sauf à donner à ce mot
escalatoires une dimension métaphysique
clairement c'est pas le cas
si c'est pour atteindre des cibles en
Russie là d'ailleurs c'est discutable si
c'est pour atteindre des cibles
militaires qui sont des endroits d'où
partent des missiles russes pour
détruire des villes
ukrainiennes honnêtement moi je ne
dirais pas un gouvernement que cette
esclavage escalade soir
un pays agressé peut avoir le droit de
se défendre de cette formule là c'est
c'est ça l'espèce de tabou que nous
formulons sur le territoire heureux
c'est à la fois parce que le Russe les
Russie la Russie et détenteurs d'armes
nucléaire donc on estime que ça risque
que qu'il faut pas prendre et d'autre
part parce que justement on veut pas
apparaître comme enveloppe en ceux qui
ont aggrave
le conflit parce que je rappelle
accessoirement que c'est un conflit
entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine c'est une affrontement entre
la Russie et l'Occident l'Europe
l'Alliance atlantique sous le regard du
Sud global sous le regard d'un tiers
parti et qui est un peu gognard et donc
l'une des motivations du président Biden
président Macron et du chancelier-sol
c'est aussi de ménager
l'un de la Chine ça dont on peut avoir
besoin y compris pour faire pression sur
la sur la sur la Russie bien sûr donc
voilà la réponse de ce que je dirais sur
le président Biden sur monsieur Macron
si j'ai si je me souviens bien il a dit
qu'il ne l'excluait pas ce qui est pas
un engagement très fort et quand tu dis
peut-être
ce ne serait pas ce serait qu'à
condition que ça n'atteigne pas les
disciples en Russie mais alors si c'est
ça ça veut dire que les deux hommes ne
sont au fond pas très élevés pas très
éloignés Marie du moulin mais ça veut
dire quoi parce que si on livre
imaginons des mirages 2000 puisqu'ils
doivent être remplacés par des rafales
donc on pourrait être dans ce cas de
figure livré des mirages 2000 à
l'Ukraine à partir du moment où on les a
livrés quelle garantie on va voir que il
serviront pas à une opération sur le sur
le sol russe mais aucune sinon la
volonté de l'Ukraine de garder le droit
international de son côté
l'Ukraine est dans une démarche qui est
justifiée puisqu'elle défend son
territoire passé à une démarche
agressive vis-à-vis du territoire russe
changerait quand même singulièrement la
donne du point de vue d'un certain
nombre de ses soutiens internationaux
l'une des l'une des questions qui à mon
avis
explique aussi cette espèce de
cacophonie c'est le fait que les
Ukrainiens sans doute pas expliqué
pourquoi ils auraient besoin de ces
avions à ce stade de cette de la guerre
l'une des surprises qu'on a eu au début
de la guerre c'est le fait que les
Russes n'aient jamais réussi à prendre
le contrôle de l'espace aérien de
l'Ukraine parce que la défense aérienne
ukrainienne les en a empêché
aujourd'hui il y a un vrai besoin de
défense entière aérienne et qui auquel
les Occidentaux répondent en fournissant
un certain nombre de systèmes de défense
entière aériennes en revanche on ne
comprend pas très bien ce que des avions
apporteraient sauf peut-être en termes
d'appui aériens à des opérations de
contre-offensives terrestre mais ça les
Ukrainiens pour l'instant ne l'ont à ma
connaissance pas expliqué alors on va
maintenant parler de de l'Union
européenne nouveau chapitre dans ce
débat le processus d'entrée de l'Ukraine
dans l'Union européenne je propose à
Mathias Arès de nous rejoindre Mathias
bonsoir donc vous allez rencontrer le le
président de la Rada aujourd'hui
parmi les sujets que vous avez abordés
il y a donc l'Europe et bien oui depuis
le 23 juin dernier le statut de candidat
à l'entrée dans l'Union européenne a été
accordée à l'Ukraine c'est un désir fort
d'Europe qui exprime les Ukrainiens
comme la rappeler le président de la
Rada le drapeau européen n'est que le
deuxième à être officiellement entré
dans le moment national après celui de
l'Ukraine en 1991 pour lui voir entrer
son pays dans la communauté ne serait
qu'un retour naturel des choses
nous entamons le long chemin de notre
retour vers la maison de l'Union
européenne nous serons très
reconnaissants envers la France pour
tout aide qui nous sera apporté sur ce
chemin mais je tiens à souligner que
c'est grâce à la France l'Ukraine a pu
devenir candidate à l'entrée dans
l'Union européenne
alors il y a plusieurs étapes comment
comptes t'il faire et bien grâce
notamment à l'aide du Sénat français en
juillet dernier lors de la visite du
président Gérard lacher à Kiev le Sénat
signé un protocole de coopération avec
l'Ukraine pour leur apporter une aide
technique concernant leur demande
d'adhésion à lui à une aide qui sait
d'ores et déjà mise en place d'après
Rouslan Stephen Chuck
nous travaillons sur plusieurs actes
législatifs
communautaire nous travaillons au
quotidien mais je pense qu'après
l'ouverture des négociations ce travail
prendra une dimension nouvelle et plus
intense
législatives et politiques à l'Ukraine
pour avancer vers son adhésion des
mesures sur lesquelles les Ukrainiens
disent allaient très vite peuvent-ils
pour autant espérer rejoindre l'Union
dans un horizon proche c'est difficile à
dire le président Emmanuel Macron a
répété qu'il fallait envisager une
adhésion sur 15 à 20 ans les temps
européens sont longs et il faut se
rappeler des candidats de longue date la
Turquie qui patiente depuis 1999 le
Monténégro depuis 2010 la Serbie depuis
2012 est encore bien d'autres qu'il ne
faudrait pas froisser les Ukrainiens eux
sont plus ambitieux dans un entretien
journal Le Monde aujourd'hui le
président de la expliquer qu'ils
tablette sur 2024 mais il est peu
probable qu'un traitement de faveur ne
leur soit accordée merci Mathias Cédric
Perrin est-ce qu'il faut une procédure
d'exception pour l'Ukraine
écouter sur cette question pourquoi pas
je pense qu'effectivement expliquer à un
pays dans la situation dans laquelle se
trouve l'Ukraine aujourd'hui que
l'adhésion ne pourra pas se faire avant
une vingtaine d'années ça pose un
certain nombre de questions donc une
procédure accélérée pourquoi pas les
critères de Copenhague ils commencent
petit à petit à essayer de les remplir
on a vu que il y avait quelques
opérations anticorruption et ils en font
beaucoup péta dans leur visite
aujourd'hui une vague de perquisition
donc passion fonctionnaires personnelles
qui sont qui sont tentés d'être donnés
mais accélérer le processus pourquoi pas
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
parfaitement possible tout en conservant
évidemment la possibilité si toutefois
ces conditions n'étaient pas remplies de
pouvoir faire marche arrière pour
l'Union européenne mais voilà je crois
qu'on surf aussi beaucoup sur l'émotion
il faut être extrêmement prudent
vigilant
vis-à-vis de effectivement un certain
nombre de pays qui aujourd'hui attendent
depuis très longtemps leur entrée dans
l'Union européenne il faut mesurer aussi
les choses et puis je serai peut-être
pas dans le dans la dans
le sens de ce que tout ce que tout ce
que tout le monde dit mais je pense
qu'il faut être aussi prudent parce que
l'objectif derrière
primordial pour tout le monde c'est
d'arriver à une paix entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine le plus vite possible alors si
nous avions la solution peut-être que
nous aurions pu la donner aujourd'hui
mais malheureusement on l'entrevoit
guère mais en tout cas il faut aussi
mesurer que cette acte de faire entrer
rapidement l'Ukraine dans l'Union
Européenne peut avoir aussi des
conséquences potentielles sur
la nature du conflit sur les les
négociations en tout cas d'une paix que
nous espérons évidemment tous le plus
rapidement possible entre l'Ukraine et
la Russie Marie moulin effectivement
est-ce que est-ce que une accélération
du processus de d'entrée de l'Ukraine a
lieu pour être un frein à d'éventuelles
pour parler de paix on en est
malheureusement très loin de de
l'hypothèse pour parler de paix alors je
crois qu'on est très loin des deux des
deux hypothèses d'une part parce que ce
dont on parle actuellement et pourquoi
la les institutions européennes ont fixé
cette condition c'est pour l'ouverture
des négociations d'adhésion qui devrait
être examinée en fin d'année une fois
que c'est négociations d'adhésion sont
ouvertes ça peut prendre extrêmement
longtemps et il y a une raison très
simple au fait que ça permet du temps
c'est que il s'agit non seulement
d'adapter la législation ukrainienne à
la qui communautaire mais il s'agit
aussi de préparer l'Ukraine à l'entrée
dans l'Union européenne d'une manière
qui fasse que cette entrée ne détruise
pas le pays et l'économie du pays
notamment donc ça objectivement ça
prendra du temps je sais pas si ça
prendra 20 ans comme le dit le président
de la République mais je pense pas que
2024 soit un horizon raisonnable de
d'urgence ou
d'exceptions politiques quand on est
allé chercher la Grèce
quand on a été chercher l'Espagne et le
Portugal au début des années 80 on était
sur des décisions politiques et non pas
guidées économiques c'est toujours une
décision politique simplement la nature
est le même de l'Union et le l'ampleur
de de la qui liée aussi à la à
l'intensité et la profondeur de
l'intégration qui est entre les pays
européens a quand même beaucoup changé
depuis cette époque là et donc c'est un
processus qui pose un certain nombre de
questions pour l'Ukraine mais qui posent
aussi un certain nombre de questions
pour l'Union européenne intégrer un pays
de 40 millions d'habitants alors on ne
sait pas combien il y en aura à l'issue
de cette guerre parce qu'il y a quand
même plusieurs millions de réfugiés mais
intégrer un pays de cette taille de ce
poids économique de ce poids militaire
avec les structures économiques qui sont
les siennes et notamment une très forte
très fort secteur agricole ça aura des
conséquences sur le fonctionnement des
institutions sur la répartition des
fonds européens toute une série de
questions qui doivent être posées et qui
à mon avis une fois qu'elles seront
posées feront que un certain nombre de
pays déjà membres de l'Union européenne
seront peut-être moins allant sur une
accélération une intégration accélérée
deuxième élément à prendre en compte
c'est le fait qu'il y a effectivement un
certain nombre de pays qui sont déjà
dans la file d'attente depuis des années
qui ont
de grandes frustrations sur les la
lenteur de ce progrès donc il faut pas
reproduire ces frustrations avec
l'Ukraine mais il faut pas non plus
augmenter la frustration de ces pays
notamment des pays des Balkans
occidentaux en faisant en sorte qu'un
pays leur passe devant avec une
procédure accélérée Michel Duclos cette
guerre elle rattache deux fêtes
l'Ukraine à l'Europe alors on a
évidemment pas au 27 pas l'Union
européenne pas aux institutions mais de
fait une scène c'est voilà totalement
basculer côté européen et pour longtemps
sur le plan sentimental sur le plan
culturel sur le plan philosophique sur
le plan politique l'Ukraine a fait des
grands pas vers vers l'Europe au sens
noble du terme maintenant en termes
pratiques je trouve que ces histoires de
calendrier dans l'immédiat c'est très
utile que l'Ukraine fasse des gestes
mettre ses institutions en ordre pour se
rapprocher de nos normes deuxième
c'est clair que la question de
l'adhésion proprement dite ne se posera
pas
avant que la guerre soit finie
ce serait très étonnant en tous les cas
quel que soit la durée de ce conflit
troisièmement une fois que le conflit
sera terminé donc que les choses
redeviendront si non normal parce que ce
sera terrible pour la reconstruction
pour réparer les dégâts y compris
humains quand on pense au nombre
d'hommes qui meurent tous les jours donc
ce sera une saignée démographique
considérable
on sera quand même dans un autre monde
qui sera le monde de la paix ou à ce
moment-là les questions d'adhésion à
l'Europe se reposeront dans des termes
plus classiques si vous voulez donc
voilà il y a plusieurs phases et ça sert
à rien pour l'instant de se projeter
dans une situation dont on ignore ce
qu'elle sera exactement dans 10 ans par
exemple dans 5 10 ans merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce
débat bientôt sur sur public